hey everyone it's sarah register nurse  rn.com and in this video i'm going to  demonstrate how to measure chest  circumference  in an infant and of course perform hand  hygiene before beginning  to measure chest circumference you want  to get your measuring tape again you'll  be measuring this in centimeters  and you're going to take it and use the  nipple line as your guide so you're  going to wrap it around  there and then measure  it and his  is about 36 and this should be about  one to two centimeters less than what  the head circumference was  okay so that wraps up this video on how  to measure chest circumference in an  infant and be sure to check out the  other videos in this pediatrics series